figures that worked with you that I've
spoken to have told me that your
behavior did amount to bullying that
your your approach put the fear of God
to quote someone into members of your
staff you insist you are not a bully but
do you accept that others think you are
and are you confident that you're going
to remain in your post in a few months
time well I of course engaged with the
inquiry and will not comment on it at
all and certainly not comment on
Anonymous claims made through the media
which of course are in breach of the
rules of inquiry put it in other way
think you'll be exonerated and remain in
post I have nothing more to say than
I've already said I think okay so you're
not sure you're going to be exonerated
because it's an independent inquiry I'm
confident I'd be a profession at all
times okay so you think you'll be okay
I'm not going to comment on the outcome
of an inquiry which is by definition
independent
let's bring in our political editor Beth
Rigby for her thoughts on that interview
um he didn't look quite as assured as he
did on Sunday with Sophie Ridge there
Beth
well as Jay he was out and about today
because the Justice secretary was
announcing a new panel to better support
victims of major disasters be that
grenful Tower uh Hillsborough or the
Manchester bombings but of course
overshadowing every appearance he now
makes is the the allegations around
bullying and what will happen with that
inquiry just to remind you there are
eight separate complaints involving
multiple complainants it goes across a
period of time and a number of different
departments taking in the brexit
department when he was brexit secretary
the foreign office when he was foreign
secretary and the justice department as
well I've spoken to a number of people
familiar with the investigation and some
of the allegations around his conduct
including as you heard In that clip the
idea that as a boss he to quote one of
my sources put the fear of God into
those working for him and I put that to
him in that pool clip just now and I
should stress Sarah Jane that he does
deny the allegations he said to Sky News
as you were saying that if one of these
complainants are upheld he will resign
but whether he is going to be exonerated
at the moment is much less clear and
when I asked him that question three
times he just simply refused to answer
but I would say as well there are
questions too not just for Dominic ra
but for the Prime Minister now you
remember that when Rishi sunak became
prime minister he promised a government
of professionalism integrity and
accountability but questions about what
the Prime Minister knew about Dominic
Ross alleged conduct before he appointed
him Deputy Prime Minister have surfaced
again I was told by a source last month
which we reported that the Prime
Minister was told directly about what
this person described as Dominic Robb's
unacceptable Behavior but at the time
there were no no formal complaints the
Prime Minister well he wasn't then the
Prime Minister but Richie sooner became
prime minister and then went on uh to
promote uh Dominic Robb and reappoint
him as Deputy Prime Minister now number
10 when we've put those allegations to
them say that at the time Dominic Raab
was appointed there was no formal
complaint but this matters because
there's still questions around what did
Rishi sunak know when so I think there's
questions for Dominic Robb there's
questions about the prime minister's
conduct and what he knew and those
involved in the allegations and the
investigation around the bullying
complaints against leveled dominant
Robbs say that they think in a month or
so it could be concluded this inquiry by
a key a KC uh is looking into that and
the question I guess is will the Prime
Minister lose a third cabinet minister
around accusations of their conduct